these two cars the i3 m8 which we call
porn electric are sort of the ultimate
version of a better electrical vehicle
in 2008 we started the design process
for the i3 and the i8 Foreman function
really came together and we were allowed
to take aerodynamics be inspired by it
and make the cars look as if the wind
has actually designed the dynamic line
work you do see on this car in the front
you have two elements we call them the
air curtains and the air actually shoots
through the air curtains comes from
behind the front wheel up and over with
this area we call the rocker panel and
then out across the rear fender and are
cut by the rear taillight in our BMW you
shape the r3 Consul car has a very
unique platform it has what we call the
drive module which is an aluminum
chassis with a batteries are mounted
down low for low center of gravity and
mounted to that is what we call the life
module which is made out of carbon fiber
weight as you might expect is the enemy
of range when it comes to electric
vehicle batteries are very heavy and
batteries were outs of the expenses so
the use of carbon fiber allows us to
maximize a range without using the
to travel that same distance and get
roughly 80 to 100 miles in pure battery
electric mode but if you have range
anxiety we will actually have as an
option
a small gasoline motor with a small
gasoline tank which allow you to excite
some CW range 8200 miles in pure
electric and then an additional 80 100
using the gasoline motor to charge the
battery we've invested into all the
technologies there's no magic bullet we
see there's real potential in the matter
electrics as well as plug-in hybrid
vehicles and you'll see a lot more of
that going forward the iSeries was like
this idea that we can have a clean slate
clean sheet of paper hit the reset
button design something very
purpose-built the I 3 is it's not just a
concept car that won't make reality this
vehicle is something very close to this
vehicle will arrive in 2013 and the i8
will arrive in 2014 so this is a promise
not just some weird concept they were
looking at these are promises to come to
market